in the last video we numerically studied
how changes in productivity or cost
might affect your marginal cost your
average variable cost your average fixed
cost or your average total cost in this
video we're going to think about it
visually
so we constructed these curves several
videos ago to visualize how average
fixed cost trends over time as you take
that fixed cost and then you spread it
over more and more and more units you
see that that just asymptotes towards
zero as you get more and more units you
see your marginal cost curve and this is
something that you'll typically see in a
lot of textbooks it's kind of u-shaped
and we talked about where it intersects
the average variable cost that's where
the average variable cost goes from
trending down to trending up so it hits
that minimum point and the same thing
happens at average total cost it hits
the bottom of that u of average total
cost it goes from trending down to
trending up and then over time this
difference that you see between
your average total cost and your average
variable cost that difference right over
there that is your average fixed cost
and so since your average fixed costs
are asymptoting downwards you see that
this difference between average total
cost and average variable cost gets less
and less over time that they are going
to
over time converge to each other as your
average fixed cost gets closer and
closer and closer to zero
but now let's think about how these
curves might be impacted if you have
changes in productivity or cost
so let's start with a change in your
fixed costs let's say your rent goes up
what would happen then pause this video
and think about what would happen
visually
well then your average fixed cost would
shift up and it would might look
something like this your average fixed
cost might look something like this and
then what which of these other curves
also have fixed costs embedded in it
well your average total cost is a
combination of your average variable
cost and your average fixed cost so the
amount that your average fixed cost went
up for any quantity your average total
cost would also go up that amount for
that quantity so it would look something
like this it would look something like
this and once again just as before it
will trend downwards until you intersect
with your marginal cost curve and then
it'll start trending upwards
so a change in your fixed costs either
upwards or downwards would affect your
average fixed cost and would affect your
average total costs
the reason why it doesn't affect your
average variable cost is because your
average variable costs are taking out
your fixed costs or just thinking about
the variable costs and your marginal
costs are thinking about a difference in
costs between two different states of
output and the fixed costs are in either
of those so they will cancel out
what would be a change in your variable
cost let's say you have to give everyone
a pay increase well then your variable
costs will go up and your variable cost
might looks like something like this
they will just shift up
and once again they will trend downwards
until you intersect with your marginal
cost curve and then you will trade then
you will trend upwards now a tren a
change in your variable cost will also
affect your marginal cost because as you
produce more output well then you are
likely to incur more incremental costs
so then your marginal cost curve i know
this is getting very messy might start
looking something like
it might look something like that
so big picture changes in productivity
would likely affect your average
variable cost
likely affect your marginal cost
and of course average variable cost
feeds into average total cost so that
would be impacted as well but changes in
just your fixed costs would affect your
average fixed cost curve and your
average total cost